[Music]
and stop that already news Oh submitted
by chicken my people experienced food
allergies want and postures to stop
faking it and restaurant taste
who the hell is faking allergies in
restaurant yeah why would they do that
besides hipsters and other forms of
white people and people that swear that
they're gluten anti gluten or whatever
baby's gluten free remember when we were
at the cruise no this [ __ ] crazy ass
lady
so you know the people of the cruise are
all foreigners right like they have
their country like nationals no it was
bad for the staff they don't all know
English so she's chasing down this one
guy and she's like excuse me if it's
golden free and he can't really answer
because he doesn't know what gluten is
like my face is like it's it's pork or
whatever but is it gluten-free like as
if being more [ __ ] aggressive about
it is going to make him answer better
and then he's like I don't know and he
walked back into the kitchen she started
falling them watch me is it gluten-free
and I'm like damn and this [ __ ] is a
gluten Nazi this is a weird crazy yeah
so a lot of people with actual various a
lot of people with actual
life-threatening allergies are asking
people those bakers out there to stop
faking it because it's just making it
harder for people that really do have
allergies because weird they keep
hearing like oh I have an allergy to it
I have an allergy to that so it's kind
of like crying like the boy who cried
wolf or it's just like repeatedly being
said to the point where they're not even
carrot all that much anymore and it also
slows down the kitchen because they have
to send an allergy alert to the kitchen
and it just causes like a whole bunch of
commotion and so they're just saying
like you know if you don't really like
that certain ingredient or you know like
just say like can you exclude that
ingredient don't lie and say that you're
allergic because it just causes way more
problems or don't order it we're doing
older I think at the core of restaurants
just be a science we don't give a [ __ ]
and then if you go on that
going to make this what they want to
make and if you're scared of whatever go
to someplace that is does give a [ __ ]
like caters yeah yeah I don't be going
to Chinese restaurant and I hate other
rapid here of course door that's true
hold the cockroach why don't you go to a
Chinese restaurant there's a couple in
front of the maze anywhere oh come on
dude that's so crazy yeah go to one of
those places like tender greens or
whatever where everything's gonna be
fresh and organic no didn't go there you
know what it's being culturally
insensitive yeah how dare you go to a
flower restaurant and say oh you have
your thumb in the bowl
I'm supposed to happen yes they're
supposed to bring out the fall with
their [ __ ] thumbs inside the block oh
I'm asking so the whole extra the whole
point of this is that um these people
are going to restaurants and they're
like oh can you hold you know whatever
right because they just don't want it in
there is that the focus I'm allergic to
leafy green there's multiple reasons so
that's one of them the fact that we just
don't want that ingredient because
they're picky even just like I am
allergic to that one ingredient you know
so that's one another one is because
apparently there's been like like people
in the media saying if you want to cheat
the the system just say that you're
allergic to gluten and then that's how
you'll get less fat in your food certain
things like that like a little hack that
if you say you're allergic to a certain
thing then you can you can raise your
chances to lose weight but they're not
backfires cuz every time they get like
one of those allergy notices in the
kitchen now they're like who the sauce
doesn't have the allergy so now they
just don't they're not that strict with
their requirements anymore yeah and then
people that are actually allergic like
with life-threatening allergies are
dying
yeah [ __ ] BJ's yeah they're scared to
even like dine out because then like
they don't even know if like the servers
can are really taking their allergy
serious because they hear so many people
having these allergies and it's really
just causing a lot more harm go to
college and for me not to melt that [ __ ]
happened to my niece she recently had to
go to the doctor for allergic to but I
forgot what it was but they
cross-contaminated something at the
jumbo
oh and then they're kind of gym buddies
Jamba Juice Jamba Juice smoothie place
you got your axe are evil yeah because
like it's not your fault but all I'm
saying is some people need to understand
that let's say there's this banana and
you have your glove on and you talk and
handle the banana and someone has a food
allergy and you go hold on let me get
your order okay you still got the banana
on your [ __ ] fingers and then you do
something else
you're cross contaminating instead of
taking up a glove you know and then you
individually for each order you clean
and make sure that the surface and
everything isn't touching but some
people don't know that you know so but
most people would fool that food
allergies though like me I've been
living with food outages all my life I
just don't go to those restaurants or I
don't eat it I mean if I'm allergic to
beef
I go to seafood restaurants you know or
like I look at the menu and I know that
this item is going to have a lot of
cream or whatever and I'm not going to
eat it ya already picked it out of a
sign that says we don't give a [ __ ]
about allergies there's some some
restaurants right do get we'll talk
about others and you can choose the
right one oh my god when you're an organ
donor and how's it like the sticker on
your idea could be like a sticker on the
restaurant yeah
reading will be flooding and stupid ugly
for me to go to Japan and then go to a
cat cafe and like can you guys hold the
cat please I am allergic my god don't
bring out the cat just a coffee yeah why
not there's probably a lot of fakers out
there that they don't really realize
like all the harm that it's causing by
staking their allergies so if you guys
out there faking allergies now you know
like the consequences there's people
that are really getting affected jump
them at this even when I think so would
you yeah but hey mister [ __ ] allergy
car they can't produce it because
allergies I remember no I
I should get one yeah but they're saying
like to spot a bakery though at a
restaurant it's like for this one
instance they did this one example work
there was this woman and she ordered
some dessert that had banana in it and
that she made a big ass
about it like I'm allergic to banana I
can't have banana involve a little
banana banana but whatever at the end of
it she ended up eating that same thing
so it had banana in it so like clearly
she wasn't allergic what are just
causing a big a scene just for no reason
mmm well I know that well I don't have
the same experience because I don't have
a life-threatening allergy it's just ink
it's just that minor inconvenience
because I'll get eczema so like a couple
days later I'm like oh my god that ice
cream was bomb but like I'm paying for
right now but people with like fatal
allergies they got to carry those epi
pens around here yeah and I know like
it's as severe as like the [ __ ]
moisture of a lemon or whatever like the
dust of a peanut and it's you can't even
see it and then they you know it's like
you licked it and then it you could get
a crazy reaction so if that of a
friend's wife that is uh has not what is
it called
that's allergic to gluten okay yeah a
real cumin our real gluten allergy and
it's so powerful that even things that
are gluten free they can get a crazy
stomach ache from it hmm just because
it's from like the same like that
manufacturing plant does have a gluten
free section but they might do some
other stuff and if it's not extreme
they'll get a stomachache from that's
why there's labels that says made in the
factory that I'll make and esperanza
yeah peanuts contains them even though
that product has no peanut or whatever
you have to let you know that's
dangerous yeah I've heard of Google
honey with us
yeah exactly people having such severe
peanut allergy that even just smelling
it in the room
I caused a crazy reaction how come no
superheroes are allergic to peanuts Ozzy
so long as I know enough superheroes
today answer but what if like spider-man
surged to peanuts they don't have any
allergies kryptonite is a form of
analogy is allergic to green rocks oh
wait do other superheroes have any kind
of like things like a quip tonight Oh
spider-man is what a [ __ ] right mate
gingers yeah gingers the earth how the
holy / yes that's his weakness like
Jerry Smith Michael I'm actually
allergic to broad beans with a broad
bean so I um there's two cuisines that
actually use this right I think it's
French and Chinese and it's like this
lima bean looking thing that's like
maybe a little bit bigger I want like a
green thing yeah I wrote that I can't
eat those at all like you die I don't
know what's going to happen I don't know
what's going to happen because it's like
I have this condition it's not Lee have
AIDS but um it it's probably doing but
keep going I don't have AIDS but um it's
a single where um I have like a like a
some sort of immune deficiency and then
I'm gonna like bless a oh yes so like if
I come into contact with this bean and
some other stuff like aspirin then my
website Souls might sort of burst or
maybe it's my red blood cells might
start to burst
so if asked if you take aspirin and the
broad bean you'll be in big trouble I
could like together
no no just separately like I don't know
if I'm gonna die or just become really
tired so what do you do when you get
headaches I don't know I just drink
water I don't take medicine when I get
headaches oh absolutely I did the Advil
brand no it's actually it's the actual
of it is actually I heard of them like
there's an actual drug and aspirin which
I'm allergic to so it's like not
ibuprofen or a sentimental things I can
take those ones okay and that's good and
I'm so lucky I don't have any manage it
and I'm so fortunate that I live in LA
because like you can just tell them like
hey can you change it to this and you
can really customize your dishes
I don't wanna get my steak in all
veggies please you can but I feel like
if it's not like a white people place
people will they'll go [ __ ] look at your
like I got a [ __ ] peanut allergy okay
I understand cuz I think I got a [ __ ]
lot of peanuts on that [ __ ]
Kent Kent these two look it's like I
told em and they still let it out
no am i driven 100 assuming for you like
attempted murder kind of thing I don't
know how you guys so place where
everything costs $5 it's hard to sue
maybe don't explain will you do it other
people not really for money they're
gonna keep doing it doesn't even know
what they're doing and I just have to
make money man I don't know I don't even
know what allergy here I don't know
allergy which out oh come on
what no I mean allergies are kind of
non-existent because like I told my mom
that I was allergic to eating anything
that kind of like similar to like a very
spinach texture so when you cook spinach
it has like this particular texture and
when I eat cook spinach I always get
canker sores in my mouth and like I told
my mom that several times which is the
[ __ ] you didn't eat it she didn't
believe it yeah she's like yeah you want
to eat it you should eat your vegetables
I love vegetables I just can't uh finish
like liar where's our like our allergy
like an American thing then cuz that's
what I think third world developing
nation people don't understand it
because they'll just die you know I mean
like they have strong genes like they
don't get sick all that stuff because
they don't have [ __ ] sickly as kids
just surviving off of pills and stuff I
do so like the lung like an American
when we grow up because that's a lot
cleaner you know we don't gain that um
immunity is that you know maybe a lot of
turbo kids might I don't know parasite
and [ __ ] like maggots and line all
that [ __ ] like all of our [ __ ] uncles
and parents and all that they [ __ ]
hate all that stuff so they got a
stronger
some have allergies at all no I mean
like if they feel funny they don't
acknowledge it as an allergy there's
just like knowledge as being a [ __ ]
yeah they're just like oh I'd rather not
eat this food because it gets me like it
makes me feel really warm or something
you know like Tiger moment under oh yeah
hot and cold Tiger Balm how you're
talking about a tiger mom on the night
day like when I show my mom like the
king cursor she's like oh you probably
just bit yourself when you're eating and
I'm like is impossible over there
so glad your fault nothing yeah it's
like you didn't drink enough water I'm
like hi drink plenty well they just go
to a massage place and get beat up so
something else hurts instead of hi-yah
they all have a runny nose but I just go
get beat up by waiting over that I don't
remember about this yeah hey guys thanks
for watching that last episode if you
haven't already make sure to hit that
subscribe button because we upload
videos every single day for you guys now
to watch more videos check them out of
here
[Music]
you